all right in case you're wondering joe
biden still had zero answers for the
lack of covert 19 testing just as the
omicron variant was surging president
joe biden headed for the beach for his
lengthy vacation naturally democrats
they wanted to know where oh not joe
biden was where governor ron desantis
was including congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez who tweeted hasn't
governor desantis been inexplicably
missing for like two weeks as it turns
out governor desantis was working in
tallahassee and also was with his wife
while she was receiving cancer
treatments ocasio-cortez what was she
doing she was down in miami enjoying a
massless vacation in the state of
florida with videos of her and a crowded
club dancing the night away massless and
from the pandemic through ripping
through her home city of new york city
where nearly 20 percent of the
population estimates show have omicron
but according to the congresswoman any
cris criticism of her vacation
and i don't get this part is somehow
sexually motivated
i you'll have to explain that to me it's
time for rational adults take back the
swamp and state houses all across the
country put an end to this covid 19
madness once and for all joining us now
florida governor ron desantis governor i
actually talked to people on your staff
you were in tallahassee most of the time
and when you weren't in tallahassee you
were with your wife and by the way our
thoughts and prayers are with her as
she's going through her treatments
yes sean i mean when people try to say
that that's a vacation i think anyone
that's gone through those treatments
would not agree that chemotherapy is a
vacation and so my wife has had to go
through that i've accompanied to all
those treatments trying to be a
supportive husband and so so that's what
we were doing on the one day where i
didn't have anything on my public
calendar because it is a private matter
but if people are going to lie we're
going to fight back and i can tell you
when you have people
like that congresswoman
who
rip florida because we're open who say
you need lockdown policies and then the
first chance they get they come running
down to my state if i had a dollar for
every lockdown politician that's done
that over the last two years i'd be
awfully wealthy right now
i gotta laugh that's funny how did we
end up now you ended up when joe biden
first talked about the vaccine mandate
he also then began buying or buying out
all the monoclonal antibodies and was
rationing something that we didn't have
a shortage of but you decided to spend
your own floridian money and buy it
yourself how do you explain not having
enough tests available enough
monoclonals available and enough
antivirals available when we know that
they work how is that even possible
well i think with the with the
monoclonals uh that is absolutely
leading uh to people dying because we
saw when we put in our sights this
summer in florida to deal with the delta
wave we kept tens of thousands of people
out of the hospital we saved thousands
of lives by providing that treatment so
that should have been replicated in all
these other states but instead what
biden and his cronies have done they've
seized control of all the monoclonal
antibodies so yes when we were in the
pinch i bought some myself none of the
governors now are able to do that
because the feds have seized control so
we're in a situation where we've now
asked for 40 000 more every week because
i have people that i could help and they
are holding on to it and they're not
distributing it and the way we need it
to be distributed you you just you had
these centers all across florida free of
charge to anybody that had a break that
was when we
first had the first breakthrough cases
with delta it quickly ended delta in
your state and now they're not available
at this point and you can't even buy
your own
i just read that today
well we they give us some they give us
some but they don't give us as much as
we need so why we built an
infrastructure florida and sean we could
scale up to two to three times the
number of treatments that they're
sending us and we could make those
readily available we've asked them to do
that
we have sites that will be turned on
additional sites within less than 24
hours if
they send us the medication so we're
asking them to send it to us we know it
will help people and uh the fact that is
they've had a lot of time to plan for
this you have to talk to the the
producer of rejection we don't know that
they they well
well the federal government says there's
no shortage but if there's not then why
are they not sending what these people
need i think they may have not purchased
enough and i think that's probably the
root of why they're being so scarce with
it
all right well our prayers uh we've been
friends a long time our prayers to your
wife as she goes through that harsh
treatment